ja meine damen und herren und da sehen
wir schon carsten schneider den neuen
staatsminister im kanzleramt
ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung ein
alter bekannter ihrem parlament mit 22
jahren
nämlich hier ein und ist jetzt mit 46
jahren wirklich ein alter hase nun also
staatsminister im kanzleramt ost
beauftragter und erhält jetzt hier die
eröffnungsrede für den bereich
bundeskanzleramt wolfgang schmidt hat
vielleicht termine oder hat carsten
schneider folgt gelassen ich weiß es
nicht genau
jedenfalls wird er hier an diesem platz
dem ja bestens bekannt ist nicht am
rednerpult den nächsten punkt einleiten
fünf minuten lang hat er bezahlt
bundeskanzleramt dazu gehört ja auch der
bereich kultur und ostdeutschland und
mit ostdeutschland wird es anfangen und
carsten schneider ist genau der richtige
denn er ist der ausbau aufzuhalten der
bundesregierung die bundeswehr ja in der
vorgängerregierungen kastenstände eines
staatssekretärs an gesucht waren
wirtschaftsministerium jetzt ist hier
also als staatsminister
im bundeskanzleramt lassen schneider
ja frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen auch für mich ein
perspektivwechsel nach 20 jahren von da
ein parlament jetzt von der regierung
vielen herzlichen dank für die
glückwünsche die mich erreicht habe ich
will auch vor den für europäer sagen
deren büro ich gewonnen habe vielen
herzlichen dank auch mal viel bilden die
machtübergabe die in deutschland
stattgefunden hat ganz fair und ich will
ihnen zu sagen dass die bundesregierung
alles tun wird auch die opposition
ausführlich zu unterrichten alle rechte
wahrzunehmen aber vor allen dingen auch
die auch stark mit einzubinden das meine
ich vor allen dingen auch bezogen auf
für den themenkomplex für den ich
verantwortung trage
ostdeutschland diese debatte heute jetzt
die zum kanzleramt etat werden noch über
kultur und integration die kollegin
sprechen ich werde diese aspekte aus
deutschland heraus greifen und ihnen ein
angebot machen die bundesregierung hat
mit der klaren entscheidung des
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz der es den
beauftragten vorher mein kollege
wanderwitz vom wirtschaftsministerium in
das kanzleramt transferiert da ist eine
klare wichtige politische entscheidung
das erste mal war das schon so gewesen
und jetzt noch und es ist dann gewann
das hat sich nicht bewährt wenn man
sowohl die sichtbarkeit als auch die
politische durchsetzbarkeit und
durchsetzung der interessen die man
strukturpolitisch hat und die einheit zu
verwenden um wirtschaftskraft
voranzubringen um universität zu stärken
haben will dann braucht man ist wirklich
an der spitze es ist ein klares
bekenntnis auch von olaf scholz für die
region für ostdeutschland ist eine klare
verpflichtung auch der bundesregierung
diese entscheidung auch etwas folgen zu
lassen das heißt sie können uns
tatsächlich messen
will aber auch eins sagt happ diese
debatten verfolgt immer hier im
bundestag eine kollegin butter ist da
ich war immer eher general ist als der
spezialist für den osten ich bin da
geboren ganz klar dass mir gefehlt hat
teilen mal dass es nur unter
ostdeutschen geführt wurden ich möchte
gerne dass das interesse die neugierde
wie wir einander in diesem land haben
ist eine bevölkerung aber auch im
bundestag nicht in so schubladen der
landesgruppen ist sondern allgemein
gemeinsam daran hat es in letzten
debatten hier gemangelt das hat auch
glaube ich gesellschaftlich unserer in
unserem land zu wenig zusammenhalt und
zu wenig außer in den letzten jahren
gegeben wir hatten 30 jahre deutsche
einheit die einheits kommission mit
wichtigen ergebnissen die auch die
letzte bundesregierung beschlossen hat
ich nehme sie kollege müller
als als leitschnur um die empfehlungen
dort um zu umzusetzen einige sind teil
des koalitionsvertrages einige werden
wir hier im bundestag verhandeln müssen
und es geht auch gar nicht um eine
sonderbehandlung sondern es geht darum
dass wir immer noch trotz 30 jahren
trotz unglaublich
viele finnen investiert milliarden
unglaublicher brüche im biografie von
bürgerinnen bürgern ingenieure die
arbeitslos worden eine umschulung
gemacht haben und danach in einem viel
niedrigeren
russland angefangen haben es geht immer
noch um die statistik wenn man sich die
löhne anschaut und guckt auf die
bundesdeutsche karte man sieht immer
wieder die ddr nämlich mit den geringen
einkommen das muss sich dringend ändern
bei ganz viel selbstbewusstsein war vor
einigen auch integration im sinne von
ein ordentliches leben zu führen können
eine rente zu haben davon lebt dass man
ordentliche löhne und gehälter auch
bekommt und die zeiten des lohndumpings
müssen in ostdeutschland vorbei sein das
ist ja aufgabe grund
ich sehe dass ich weiß wir haben der
tarifautonomie
wir haben aber eine klare politische
entscheidung getroffen nämlich dass wir
mindestlöhne einführen und ich habe die
situation bei mir in erfurt leute für
350 450 euro gearbeitet haben und ich
davon leben konnten jetzt wollen die
mindestlohn erhöhen auf 12 und wir
wollen die tarifbindung stärken und ist
auch eine frage von selbst ermächtigung
und befähigung das heißt man muss
allerdings dann auch bereit sein einen
arbeitskampf zu führt man muss auch
bereit sein und zweifel eine
gewerkschaft einzutreten diese freiheit
diese entscheidung zu treffen auf diese
verantwortung die will ich auch
zurückgeben und auch aufforderung
verstehen die mit einem neuen eigenen
selbstbewusstsein worden wird das
zumindest us-regierung mit unterstützen
dass wir mehr tarifbindung ordentliche
zukunftsfähige arbeitsplätze in
ostdeutschland haben
und ein letztes vielleicht
es gibt immer auch um struktur
politischen fragen in den ersten
jahrzehnten haben wir vor einigen
autobahnen und eisenbahn gebaut die
trasse von berlin nach münchen über
erfurt ist ein beispiel jetzt geht es
darum dass wir innovationen und
investitionen in innovation voranbringen
das heißt nicht dass an der nach sorgen
der sozialpolitik sondern wir wollen
dass wir die die neuesten trends nehmen
wir zum beispiel die
wasserstofftechnologie die ganz klar im
mittelpunkt stehen wird dass die dann in
ostdeutschland aber auch vorneweg mit
investiert werden und dass sie dort
stattfinden das kann der zug aus game
changer sein und ich möchte dass wir als
bundesregierung bedanke mich bei den
kollegen kollegen dafür dass sie dafür
auch bereits signalisiert haben dort
auch nicht so zu unterstützen dass diese
entscheidung so fallen das im osten da
tatsächlich zukunft ist
selbstbewusstsein zukunft und ich lade
die kollegen kollegen der opposition
dazu kritische dialog insgesamt mit 1
vielen dank
carsten schneider war dass der neue
ostbeauftragte der bundesregierung
angesiedelt im kanzleramt und die
nächste rednerin war auch die letzte
legislaturperiode im kanzleramt
angesiedelt dorothee bär ist jetzt in
dieser legislaturperiode die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
für die vision csu fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
lieber herr staatsminister schneider
vielen herzlichen dank für die
freundlichen worte anlässlich über
unserer wirklich sehr sehr freundlichen
amtsübergabe ich gebe zu ich habe das
büro nicht gerne geräumt aber wenn ich
es gerne jemanden übergeben hätte dann
ihnen also vielen herzlichen dank
nochmal für die sehr netten worte an
dieser stelle ich hätte mich jetzt
allerdings gefreut direkt hier auch
claudia roth antworten zu dürfen hat
papa grad von kanzleramtsminister fahren
dass sie noch in quarantäne ist deswegen
wird sie uns sicherlich am bildschirm zu
schauen sehr geehrte frau
kulturstaatsministerin auch an dieser
stelle alles gute auf unserer fraktion
auf eine gute zusammenarbeit der kultur
politikerinnen und kulturpolitiker und
ich darf sie herzlich lösung noch dass
sie in der nächsten sitzungswoche dann
wieder bei uns sein werden
die grünen dürfen auch klatschen finde
ich
claudia roth hat neulich in einem
interview gesagt dass kultur das
grundnahrungsmittel unserer gesellschaft
seit dem kann ich nur zustimmen
kultur ist systemrelevant und all
diejenigen die es vielleicht viele jahre
lang als nice to have oder als wir haben
es ohnehin schon gesehen haben denen
kann ich nur sagen gerade in der
pandemie hat man ganz besonders gesehen
was es bedeutet wenn eben kultur nicht
stattfindet wenn wir nicht die
möglichkeit haben abends spontan
irgendwo ins theater zu gehen ins kino
zu gehen zum poetry slam uns irgendwo
auch noch einmal anzuschauen bildenden
künste was unsere künstlerinnen und
künstler in unserem land leisten und
deswegen ist es ganz wichtig dass wir
kunst kultur wieder einen ganz neuen
einen wichtigen stellenwert in unserer
gesellschaft einräumen und ich darf
ihnen heute von der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion vielleicht ein paar
punkte noch auf den weg geben weil wir
in den letzten jahren wirklich sehr sehr
viel nicht nur erfahrung hatten sondern
meines erachtens auch die kulturpolitik
in unserem land federführend gestaltet
und auch sehr gut gestaltet haben wir
haben sie geprägt wir haben erfolgreiche
kultur politik betrieben was ist
erfolgreiche kulturpolitik nicht nur
aber auch natürlich ein ganz starker
etat des bkm budgets unter bernd neumann
und monika grütters auf über zwei
milliarden euro angewachsen wir haben
sondermaßnahmen zur pandemie bewältigung
gestartet das programm neustart kultur
im sonder vor des bundes für
kulturveranstaltungen als insgesamt 6,5
milliarden euro das ist eine historische
zahl und ich finde daran muss sich auch
die ampel messen lassen und darf nicht
dahinter zurückfallen
es bedeutet aber auch dass wir als
unions politiker in der kultur die ganze
bandbreite im blick haben einige
beispiele habe ich schon erwähnt aber
kultur ist von der filmwirtschaft bis
zur erinnerungskultur von der klub
wirtschaft bis zum denkmalschutz vom
berliner opernhaus bis hin zum kleinen
kinobetreiber auf dem land und mir
persönlich ist es besonders wichtig auch
gerade die kultur in den ländlichen
räumen zu betonen das darf nicht hinter
das großstädtische angebot zurückfallen
das war und ist uns als union ein ganz
ganz großes herzensanliegen die kultur
im ländlichen raum
und ich sage als jemand der wirklich
auch mit begeisterung auch einen
zweitwohnsitz in berlin hat ich freue
mich dass berlin drei opernhäuser habe
ich freue mich dass wir ein stadtschloss
haben aber gleichzeitig muss man sagen
würde das nicht reichen für eine große
kulturnation ohne die kursächsischen
winterträume im vogtland frau
präsidentin beispielsweise ohne den
kultursommer im landkreis tübingen den
musikalischen sommer in ostfriesland den
kissinger sommer in bad kissingen oder
auch sehr geehrte frau kollegin
schenderlein das full force festival in
ferropolis in sachsen anhalt um nur
einige beispiele zu nennen werden wir
kulturell auf jeden fall wesentlich
ärmer und deswegen haben die auch in der
letzten legislaturperiode eine ganze
reihe an initiativen und
förderprogrammen auf den weg gebracht
wie kultur in ländlichen räumen oder die
sogenannten land millionen die ganz ganz
wichtig sind das zukunftsprogramm kino
der film liegt mir seit vielen jahren
ganz besonders am herzen und auch da
würde ich mir wünschen dass kino das
filmwirtschaft wieder stärker in den
mittelpunkt gerückt wird auch in den
nächsten jahren und dass kulturpolitik
nicht nur in der neuen regierung eine
auswärtige kulturpolitik ist nicht
ausschließlich eine außenpolitische note
hat sondern dass wir tatsächlich
natürlich eine internationale und
europäische vernetzung haben aber dass
wir angesichts der gravierenden
schwierigkeiten vor denen unsere
kulturlandschaft derzeit steht auch
gerade wegen der pandemie dass wir unser
besonderes augenmerk auf die vielfalt in
unseren 16 bundesländern lägen wir haben
als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion viele
fragen an die neue regierung wie genau
wollen sie die soziale lage der
kulturschaffenden verbessern wo bedenken
sie in ihrer kulturpolitik die vielen
ehrenamtlichen ich habe gehört von
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen das in
der letzten legislaturperiode das thema
bürgerschaftliches engagement im
unterausschuss so wichtig war dass auch
diejenigen geht es gemeinsam regieren
die ampel parteien versprochen haben
einen ordentlichen ausschuss zu machen
wo ist der fehlanzeige auch david für
die ehrenamtlichen nicht das getan was
sie sich vorgenommen haben was es mit
den themen der kulturellen bildung
gerade in der pandemie ist es eben auch
so wichtig der heranwachsenden
generation
museumsbesuche als etwas
selbstverständliches nahe zu bringen
ihnen zu zeigen was kunst was musik für
unser leben bedeuten und ich hoffe dass
wir deutschland als breite und
vielfältige kulturlandschaft weiter
fördern da gibt's wahnsinnig viel nicht
nur in franken vor allem dabei besonders
aber wir sind insgesamt ein sehr reiches
ein großes kultur erbe und weil wir das
sind haben wir auch eine ganz große
verantwortung da werden wir als union
immer ein auge drauf haben daran werden
wir sie messen und eine parlaments fort
etienne alleine wird uns keinen
kulturellen zumal das geschehen
herzlichen dank
der täter war das positions- und
fraktion hier in der debatte zum
bundeskanzleramt zur politik der
bundesregierung halte besonders zum
bundeskanzler hand mit den themen aus
deutschland integration und kultur
nächste rednerin ist filiz polat
parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
bündnis 90 die grünen hier im deutschen
bundestag
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben es geschafft wir brechen auf
in ein neues jahrzehnt der gesellschaft
der vielen frau staatsministerin alaba
radovan wir freuen uns über ihre
ernennung und auf die zusammenarbeit mit
ihnen und ihrem team im namen der
gesamten fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
es wird schluss sein mit der ausgrenzung
rhetorik meine lieben kolleginnen und
kollegen der union die seit jahren die
debatten um migration und integration
vergiftet haben der gemeinsame geist der
diese koalition trägt ist dass alle
respektiert alle gleichberechtigt mit
gestalten alle angstfrei leben und sich
als gleiche begegnen liebe kolleginnen
wir freuen uns auf diesen
paradigmenwechsel in der migrations und
integrationspolitik und wir laden alle
herzlich ein unsere migrations
gesellschaft mitzugestalten und
ich weiß
das generation von einwanderern und
ihren kindern und besonders meine
generation die wie ich durch die
rassistischen ausschreitungen und
angriffe in den 90er jahren politisiert
wurden sich besonders auch die reform
des staatsangehörigkeitsrechts freuen
wir beenden die schleichende aushöhlung
des staatsangehörigkeitsrechts und
knüpfen an die erste große reform unter
rot grün aus dem jahr 2000 mehr als 20
jahre nach der unsäglichen doppelpass
kampagne der union liebe kolleginnen
wird endlich die einbürgerung für alle
unter hinnahme der mehrstaatigkeit
möglich sein
und damit sieht die vernunft vor dem
nationalstaatlichen
exklusivität denken liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
nicht
würdigen wir endlich die lebensleistung
der sogenannten gastarbeiter innen und
vertragsarbeiter innen generation durch
die erleichterung bei den einbürgerungen
und der abschaffung der einbürgerung
unter kultur vorbehalt liebe spd
kolleginnen dies sind meilensteine in
der einbürgerungspolitik die endlich den
lebensrealitäten vieler menschen in
unserem land gerecht wird
dazu gehört auch unser gemeinsames
vorhaben die kettenduldungen endlich
abzuschaffen
unser anspruch ist es die teilhabe von
einwanderinnen bestmöglich zu fördern
dafür starten wir erneut 15 jahren nach
einführung der integrations und
sprachkurse eine integrationsoffensive
und würdigen das jahrzehntelange
engagement der
migrantenselbstorganisationen wer weiß
das besser als die liebe kollegin durch
eine strukturelle förderung
wir werden rassismus an der wurzel
packen das heißt für uns ran an die
strukturen rein in die institutionen und
mehr finanzielle sicherheit für alle
akteurinnen die sich tagtäglich dafür
einsetzen liebe kolleginnen lange zu
lange überwog in unserer migration und
integrationspolitik das restriktive das
ausschließende dem wollen wir ein ende
machen deshalb freue ich mich auf
unseren gemeinsamen aufbruch in der
gesellschaft der vielen vielen dank für
ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
und hier sehen wir schon dem nächsten
redner in dieser debatte markt jungen
ist der kulturpolitische sprecher der
arctic sea ohne das wort im nächsten
redner dr markt jungen auf die
fraktionen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte abgeordnete und
regierungsvertreter liebe zuschauer an
den bildschirmen es war friedlich mehr
als heute chef im dritten anlauf der cdu
der ende der 90er jahre den begriff der
deutschen leitkultur in die politische
debatte eingeführt hat geprägt hat
diesen begriff übrigens der politologe
bassam tibi ein migrant aus syrien der
besser verstanden hat als die
linksgrünen deutschen ideologen das
verbindliche wert vorgaben seitens der
mehrheitsgesellschaft essentiell wichtig
sind für eine erfolgreiche integration
wie recht er hatte meine damen und
herren das können wir fast täglich auf
den straßen und den schulen und anderswo
in unserem land beobachten schon damals
haben die eigenen parteifreunde sie herr
merz er ist ja nicht da ich sage es in
abwesenheit als einsamen rufer in der
wüste stehen lassen und wo stehen sie
heute sie haben nichts besseres zu tun
als eine brandmauer gegen die afg zu
errichten und jeden aus der cdu zu
werfen der mit uns kooperiert ich sage
ihnen die alternative für deutschland
ist die einzige kraft in diesem land die
ihre damaligen richtigen ideen noch
weiter trägt und verteidigt und wenn sie
uns zum feind erklären dann hängen sie
ihr fähnchen in den wind des zeitgeistes
um der reinen machterhaltung wählen das
ist schändlich herr merz und liebe cdu
kehren sie um von diesen verrat an allen
konservativen werten nutzen sie die
chance der opposition machen sie mit uns
eine politik für deutschland
sie von der cdu sind ja leider
wesentlich verantwortlich das sind 16
jahren scheibchenweise deutschland
abschaffung unter angela merkel das
modell multikultur mit gleichrangigen
parallelgesellschaften heute quasi zur
staatsdoktrin geworden ist wir haben es
gerade gehört im koalitionsvertrag der
ampel nennt sich das beschönigend
einheit in vielfalt die aber achtung
durch eine ganzheitliche diversity
strategie erzwungen werden soll frau
staatssekretärin aller bali radovan sie
wünschen sich so lässig im interview das
in zwölf jahren deutschland als in fünf
jahren in deutschland als vielfältiges
einwanderungsland sichtbar wird in den
medien der politik in der öffentlichen
verwaltung das bedeutet das bedeutet
quoten nach ethnischer zugehörigkeit in
vielen fällen und konkreten einzelfällen
also gezielte benachteiligung
autochthone deutsche bei
stellenbewerbungen sprechen sie uns
nicht mehr von rassismus wenn sie solche
diskriminierenden ethno quoten
tatsächlich einführen wollen werte rbl
parteien nicht ethnische zugehörigkeit
darf entscheiden auch nicht das
geschlecht sondern einzig die
qualifikation und die loyalität zu
diesem land und seinen werden so steht
es im grundgesetz
und diese loyalität
erreichen sie nicht indem sie die
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft nach fünf
oder gar drei jahren verschenken quasi
und mehrfach staatsbürgerschaften zu
lassen ich möchte keine deutschen
polizisten oder staatsbeamten die in
ihrer freizeit erdogan oder anderen
fremden potentaten zujubeln und dort ihr
kreuz machen frau claudia roth in
quarantäne ich wünsche von hier aus gute
gesundheit wir wissen ja aus youtube
dass sie die türkei lieben aber gerade
deshalb kann ihnen das ja wohl auch
nicht recht sein das bewusstsein dass
deutschland eine über jahrhunderte
gewachsene kulturnation ist fehlt im
koalitionsvertrag fast völlig
stattdessen lesen wir von
barrierefreiheit diversität geschlechter
gerechtigkeit und nachhaltigkeit und vor
allem von green culture das gesamte
kulturlebens soll in den dienst der
grünen klima religionen gestellt werden
damit degradieren sie die kultur zum
propaganda instrument ihrer
ideologischen energiepolitik schweigens
peter künftig von freiheit der kunst
denn was sie betreiben ist das genaue
gegenteil sie untergraben diese
systematisch ich komme zum schluss die
ostdeutschen haben ein feineres gespür
für solche latent totalitäre tendenzen
wegen ihrer 40-jährigen sozialistischen
diktatur erfahrung und wenn der
ehemalige ost-beauftragte wanderwitz
meinte seine landsleute seien deshalb
noch nicht in der demokratie angekommen
man könne nur auf die nächste generation
hoffen dann soll er sich bitte fragen wo
wir selbst in der demokratie angekommen
ist nach 40 jahren partei sozialisation
was für eine unfassbare arroganz der
macht sein nachfolger redezeit wird auch
bereits überschritten
sage ich zum schluss nur hören sie auf
die regierungskritischen stimmen aus der
ausreise steuern schrittes ländern
bereits deutlich überschritten kommt
dieses land auch wieder auf marko ist
kindern
[Applaus]
mag jungen war das aus der fdp fraktion
habe wurde hier auch an seine redezeit
erinnert laut plan soll es heute bis
halb neun uhr abends gehen allerdings
hängt der bundestag schon in seiner
tagesordnung von daher gehen wir jetzt
schon davon aus dass ist sie heute etwas
länger sind dementsprechend
für die öffnung brauche ich jetzt da
sich hier an die redezeit erinnert wird
nächster gegner ist hagen reinhold ist
die fraktion
so geschafft sehr geehrte präsidentin
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren der
staatsminister carsten schneider ich bin
genauso wie sie erfreut darüber dass wir
diese debatte unter anderem über
ostdeutschland unter dem label
bundeskanzleramt führen zeichne
aufwertung des postens das freut mich
ungemein de warum freut mich das nicht
so sehr weil ich die unterschiede sehen
die unterschiede gibt es in diesem land
zwischen ost und west genauso wie
zwischen nord und süd und zwischen stadt
und land das ist gar nicht die frage
aber die herausforderung in
ostdeutschland die sind gewaltig sie
haben riesen transformationsprozess in
norddeutschland vor uns die werden
unsere aufmerksamkeit fordern und
deshalb ist im kanzleramt angesiedelte
ost beauftragter goldrichtig angesetzt
und mit transformation kann man ganz
unterschiedlich umgehen und das zeigt
auch dass diese ampel koalition anders
damit umgehen will man kann sie
verwalten man kann feuchten hände
schlacht geben man kann sicherlich auch
im bankangestellten zum it fachmann um
schule und sagen
such dir in den neuen berufen sie ist
jetzt bald gibt job oder man gestaltet
transformation und gestaltet sie so dass
man von denen lernt die transformation
durch machen das können wir in
ostdeutschland übrigens perfekt mit 30
jahren nicht nur einmal durchgemacht und
sagten wir lernen von dir weil wir diese
transformationsprozess in den
gebrauchten bundesländern nämlich in den
nächsten jahren auch haben werden das
zeigt dass wir die lebensleistung der
ostdeutschen anerkennen diese
herausforderung und wir wissen das sind
große in nächster zeit anerkennen und
die für das ganze land in deutschland
gebrauchten und das ist eine andere
anerkennung der leute die sie auch jahre
lang vermisst haben und diese abwehr
koalition gibt in das zeichen dass sie
die erwarten können von uns
die transformationsprozesse sind deshalb
riesig war die rohstoffe der
vergangenheit ob das gut oder stahl war
hin zu neuen rohstoffen wasserstoff da
sahen wir werden die vitalität haben wir
haben ein wandel in der demografie all
das schlägt und ostdeutschland zu
allererst zu und deshalb wollen wir dem
nicht als neue regierung uns auch
hinstellen und sagen wir brauchen eben
nicht nur neue qualifikation sondern die
firmen die die jobs anbieten die die
zukunft bietet und deshalb haben wir so
was wie eine agentur für transfer und
innovation die gerade kleineren
universitäten erlaubt zu kmu s und auch
zur start ups neue ideen zu
transferieren und diese wo sind denn
diese kleinen universitäten sie sind in
ostdeutschland ein großartiger schritt
wir werden diese projekte für
wasserstoff und chips gerade da
ansiedeln automatisch schon in
ostdeutschland nicht nur weil wir neue
sachen ansiedeln wollen in
ostdeutschland sondern gerade wenn ich
chips mehr angucken in ostdeutschland
bereits in cluster ist wir werden grw
mittel aufstocken wir wären die
fördersysteme so anpassen dass sie diese
transformationsprozesse im
wirtschaftssystem fördern und das die
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
schaffen all das freut mich weil es
zugeschnitten ist auf die bereiche die
transformation in den nächsten jahren
erleben werden aber und deshalb bin ich
heilfroh dass meine nachbarin rehm dass
frau staatsministerin
alvarado waren hier genauso dabei ist
wir werden erstmals informationsprozess
vor uns haben wo es gar nicht reicht die
leute mitzunehmen die jetzt in den 3 da
sind denn wir brauchen darüber hinaus
noch deutlich mehr nicht nur in
ostdeutschland in ganz deutschland und
deshalb braucht das einwanderungsland
integration mehr denn je das können sie
das kannst du in moskau geborenen
ostdeutschland in berlin aufgewachsen
besonders gut einschätzen aber wir
brauchen es auch insgesamt und zwar nach
klaren regeln weil wir wissen wen wir in
den nächsten jahren in deutschland
vermissen werden weil wir wissen dass
400.000 leute pro jahr jetzt schon
vielen und deshalb müssen wir nicht auf
den zufall bauen sondern auch klare
regeln und ein punktesystem die uns
erlauben jedem fachmann in deutschland
einzuladen und mitzumachen dieses land
zu gestalten in den nächsten jahren den
wir brauchen und dabei sind fachleute
gott sei dank nicht wie in vergangenheit
leute bei denen man erst auf dem
lohnzettel ablesen kann oder an dem
studiengang ganz im gegenteil ich kenne
noch betriebe nicht nur in
ostdeutschland sondern in einer ganzen
republik für die ist einfach man schon
einen führerschein hat und auch den
werden wir in nächster zeit brauchen
bevor wir zu solchen ereignissen kommen
wie sie in england jetzt schon der fall
sind und deshalb braucht es eine
integration in diesem land deshalb
braucht es ein klares konzept was auf
die lebensleistung der leute baut ja wir
werden den menschen viel zumuten in
ostdeutschland durch diese
transformation aber wir geben ihnen
zeichen dass wir diesen
transformationsprozess nicht nur
gemeinsam gestalten sondern von ihnen
lernen werden und sie als gutes beispiel
für die ganze republik heranführen das
würdigte lebensleistung das ist der
unterschied zu den jahren davor und
deshalb freue ich mich auf die
zusammenarbeit und auf die nächsten
jahre war das ein großartiger schritt
wird und da wird aus dem fortschritt den
wir wagen schnell das wagnis
verschwinden und der fortschritt
entstehen da freue ich mich besonders
darauf recht herzlichen dank
für die linke hat jetzt hören will man
das wort
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die linke begrüßt dass das
thema ostdeutschland neuerdings im
bundeskanzleramt angesiedelt ist das
haben wir häufig und oft gefordert der
staatsminister schneider wir wünschen
ihnen von herzen viel erfolg und dass
die tür des bundeskanzlers und auch das
bundeskanzleramt es für sie und das
thema ostdeutschland immer weit offen
steht diese administrative aufwertung
ostdeutschlands reicht aber nicht aus
notwendig ist eine reale politische
aufwertung und das vermisse ich bislang
aus deutschland führt ein schattendasein
im koalitionsvertrag und das sind
denkbar schlechte voraussetzungen für
die nächsten jahre unlängst kam in einem
leipziger wahlkreis an junge
sozialarbeiterin auf mich zu sie
arbeitet seit 15 jahren in diesem beruf
und nun wurde ihre wohnung gekündigt die
eigentumswohnung wurde verkauft sie
kommen dass diese trotz vollzeitjobs
nicht leisten die neuen eigentümer ein
junges 25 jähriges pärchen aus solingen
haben jetzt eigenbedarf angemeldet für
sie ist es eine große ungerechtigkeit
ihrer meinung nach wird im osten nicht
selten die altersarmut der eltern geerbt
während andere aus dem westen ja einfach
die wohnung wegkaufen offen obwohl sie
offenkundig noch nicht viel aus eigener
hände arbeit geleistet und
erwirtschaftet haben ich kann diesen
frust verstehen dieses beispiel sagt ja
viel über und zu den derzeitigen
bedingungen zwischen ost und west als
vollzeit beschäftigte von denen sie im
osten im schnitt 650 euro im monat
brutto weniger als was deutsche kollegen
gleicher lohn für gleiche arbeit auch im
32 jahre nach der einheit sind wir davon
lichtjahre entfernt millionen
ostdeutsche sind weiterhin beschäftigte
zweiter klasse und der anteil der
geringverdiener besonders hoch herr
schneider wir erwarten hier konkrete
vorschläge wie sie diese ost west
spaltung des arbeitsmarktes aufheben und
entgegenwirken wollen die linke sagt
deutlich wir brauchen die angleichung
des endlich 25 von der geplanten
anhebung des mindestlohnes auf zwölf
euro pro stunde würden im osten
deutschlands 1 5 millionen menschen
profitieren aber wann kommt dieses jahr
hören denn endlich sehr geehrter
arbeitsminister her die inflation liegt
aktuell bei 5 prozent ich fordere sie
auf noch vor ostern und den beschluss
und die umsetzung der zwölf euro
mindestens zu beschließen die linke
haben sie da an ihrer seite
zwei themen die die ostdeutschen
besondere umtreiben sind völlig lang in
ihrem koalitionsvertrag die renten und
die energiepreise gleiche rente für die
gleiche lebensleistung denkst dann
rentner im osten halten noch immer im
schnitt rund 400 euro weniger im jahr
für die gleiche lebensleistung gleichen
sie die renten werde endlich an nicht
erst 2025 sondern auch in diesem jahr
denn auf ostdeutschland rollt weiter
eine lawine hat mini rente und
altersarmut zu jedem zweiten
vollzeitbeschäftigten droht eine rente
von unter 1100 60 euro netto und das
nach 45 jahren einem kompletten
arbeitsleben wir brauchen endlich ein
deutlich höheres rentenniveau
aber
was machen sie es schaffen sogar
vernünftige regelungen ab nämlich den
umrechnungsfaktor der die lohnlücke
zwischen ost und west wenigstens in der
rente etwas abgemildert hat das bedeutet
eine faktische rentenkürzung für
künftige rentnerinnen und rentnern herr
schneider korrigieren sie diese falsche
entscheidung und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wo bleiben denn die
angekündigten entlastungen der
bürgerinnen und bürger die energien
kosten gehen durch die decke die
inflation ist auf rekordniveau und das
leben wird immer teurer das trifft das
ganze land aber besonders den osten
abschließend zweierlei ist für den osten
essentiell klare perspektiven und
verlässlichkeit der bereits erreichten
vereinbarungen durch beide forderungen
zieht sich der aspekt der wertschätzung
das ist es was millionen ostdeutsche wie
die oben erwähnte sozialarbeiterin
zurecht und seit langem erwarten der
erste strukturbruch in den 1990 er
jahren hat narben und bitterkeit
hinterlassen den bevorstehenden
strukturwandel müssen wir gemeinsam
besser hinkriegen vielen dank
sören keine
inspiration hat hier doch um sich
deutlich an carsten schneider gewandten
war auf der bundesregierung für aus
deutschland dieses amt war übrigens für
im wirtschaftsministerium angesiedelt
ist jetzt im bundeskanzleramt hat
dadurch auch an stellen werk bedrohung
stellen wir deutlich gewonnen würdigen
staatsministerien rima badeen radio
orange mit migration flüchtlinge und
integration
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte die gelegenheit auch nutzen
liebe frau widmann mauz ihn für die
kollegiale übergabe und bedanke mich
dafür bedanken
die koalition steht für einen neuen
aufbruch wir wollen mehr fortschritt
respekt und zusammenhalt damit hier ein
modernes einwanderungsland sind und alle
83 millionen menschen gleiche chancen
haben damit unsere vielfalt zu einer
starken einheit wächst heute ist meine
erste bundestags rede und bis hierhin
bin ich einen langen weg gegangen ich
weiß was es heißt in einer erstaufnahme
und in einer gemeinschaftsunterkunft zu
tun ich weiß was es heißt auf eine
entscheidung der ausländerbehörde über
den aufenthaltstitel zu warten und ich
weiß welche strukturellen würden wir für
eine gleichberechtigte teilhabe aller
noch abbauen müssen die themen meines
amtes als staatsministerin begleitet
mich schon mein ganzes leben privat wie
beruflich
ich weiß also auch welche chancen unser
wunderbares land bietet arbeiten wir
gemeinsam daran dass alle menschen
dieser chancen bekommen und nutzen
können
alle
das heißt egal welcher herkunft egal in
welchem stadtteil oder dorf sie leben
egal ob hier in zweiter oder zwölfter
generation zu hause alle sollen ihren
weg gehen können wie wollen wir den
aufruf nun konkret gestalten mehr
fortschritt ein modernes
einwanderungsland braucht ein
zeitgemäßes staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
die einbürgerung ist eine wichtige
voraussetzung zur gleichberechtigte
teilhabe nur dann kann man den bundestag
und die landtag gehen und auch dorthin
gewählt werden um die fünf millionen
menschen sind seit über zehn jahren ein
fester teil unserer gesellschaft doch
sie haben aufgrund ihrer
staatsangehörigkeiten nicht dieselben
rechte es ist nicht gut für eine
demokratie wenn wohl und wahlbevölkerung
auseinanderfallen darum werden wir
schneller und besser einbürgern darum
ermöglicht mir grundsätzlich die
mehrstaatigkeit damit klopfen wir den
letzten staub der kaiserzeit aus dem
staatsangehörigkeitsgesetz
j
sofort schritt gehört auch dass die
vielfalt unserer gesellschaft überall
stimme und verantwortung hat im
bundestag sind ihr weiblicher jünger und
diverser und das muss überall so seien
in der wirtschaft und in der vorstands
etage im sportverein und im
stadtteiltreff es normal sein dass alle
die gleichen chancen haben auf die
ausbildung oder den job wir werden dafür
sorgen dass qualifikation entscheidet
nicht der name nicht das aussehen oder
die herkunft liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
mehr respekt wir wollen dass jeder
mensch einen guten zugang zu bildung und
beruf hat gute löhne für gute arbeit
wertschätzung für jede lebensleistung
das gilt auch für geflüchtete und
geduldete viele sind hoch motiviert aber
leben in unsicherheit in jedem wahlkreis
gibt es dafür bewegende beispiele bei
mir ist das eine ukrainische familie die
frau ist pflegerin im seniorenheim der
mann ist handwerker die kinder gehen zur
schule sie sind hier zu hause aber die
duldung wurde entzogen abschiebung droht
und gleichzeitig sprechen wir über ein
fachkräftemangel das kann nicht sein das
kann niemand verstehen auch die
unternehmen nicht
respekt heißt deshalb auch faire
bleibeperspektive werden die
kettenduldungen ablösung ordnung bei den
duldungsstatus ständen schaffen und wege
ebenen raus aus der duldung rein in die
perspektive der aufenthaltserlaubnis
mehr zusammenhalt wer über aufbruch und
ein modernes einwanderungsland spricht
der muss auch die kehrseiten klar
benennen
ferhat göcer hamza
leitmesse des set carlo jan willi und
vati
sie waren ein teil von uns aus unserer
mitte sie waren deutschland sie hatten
noch ihr ganzes leben vor sich doch sie
wurden im februar 2020 bei dem
rassistischen und
rechtsextremen anschlag in hanau aus dem
leben gerissen ich werde nie vergessen
was ich bei dieser nachricht gefühlt
habe das war eine zäsur
weitere grausame erinnerung gehören dazu
solingen hoyerswerda rostock
lichtenhagen halle und der mord an
walter lübke wir dürfen nicht zulassen
dass diese liste weiter geht darum sagt
darum sage ich das noch einmal auch wenn
es einige hier im saal und gerade weil
es einige hier im saal nicht hören
wollen der rechtsextremismus ist die
größte gefahr in unserem land dazu
dass man auf jährlich über 20.000
straftaten von rechts alle 22 minuten
eine straftat oft hängt es mit worten an
dem bus im supermarkt im total angegeben
nicht wollt dass wir alle dazu gehören
der kampf gegen rassismus antisemitismus
islamfeindlichkeit antiziganismus und
weiterer gruppenbezogener
menschenfeindlichkeit geht uns alle an
nicht nur die betroffenen wir sind mehr
und wir müssen das auch zeigen wir sind
alle gegen rechts
wir machen uns an die arbeit der
aufbruch ist hier und jetzt für mehr
fortschritt für mehr respekt und mehr
zusammenhalt in unserem land dafür
treten wir an herzlichen dank
das war also die erste rede von brenner
bahnen radovan im bundeskanzleramt gibt
es ja einige staatsminister
staatsministerin mit deutlich
verschiedenen aufgaben das liegt
natürlich an der besonderen politischen
bedeutung des bundeskanzleramts das muss
natürlich durch zu allen ministerien
kontakt halten und die arbeit auch
organisieren oder beziehungsweise
koordinieren von daher sind hier so
diverse themen wie kultur migration oder
eben auch aus deutschland heute hier
auch thema sap müller spricht jetzt für
die unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
zuallererst wünsche ich ihnen herr
staatsminister schneider gutes gelingen
auf gute zusammenarbeit und allzeit
schaffenskraft für die neuen
bundesländer da liegt viel arbeit vor
uns zu ihrem amtsantritt möchte ich
ihnen drei punkte mit auf den weg geben
und bevor ich die macher weil einige
auch gesagt haben das ministeramt wurde
aufgewertet muss man 1 festhalten wir
hatten 16 jahre lang eine erfolgreiche
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel die die
neuen bundesländer vorangebracht hat und
da sage ich herzlichen dank angela
merkel für 16 jahre erfolgreiche haben
und herr staatsminister wenn wir auch
diesen schulterschluss
ernst meinen zu denen sie aufgerufen
haben dann die drei punkte wir erwarten
von einer als unionsfraktion von ihnen
dass sie eine kräftige stimme sind eine
kräftige stimme für die neuen
bundesländer am kabinettstisch ja im
gleichen rang mit kabinettskollegen auch
die stimme erhebt und
diese starke stimme der staatsminister
sie sprachen vorhin von sichtbarkeit
politische durchsetzbarkeit die habe ich
persönlich zwischen den feiertagen
vermisst in einem interview mit der zeit
hat wirtschaftsminister habe folgendes
zum strukturwandel prophezeit ich
zitiere mit erlaubnis der präsidentin es
werden neue arbeitsplätze entstehen uns
geht die arbeit nicht aus ganz im
gegenteil aber damit geht einher dass
alte arbeitsplätze etwa in kohlebergbau
wegfallen oder sich verändern und das
kann individuell oder auch für regionen
eine bittere nachricht werden es wird
also auch enttäuschung und vielleicht
auch zum geben ende des zitats die
reaktion des staatsministers für neue
bundesländer
keiner
die neuen ampel parteien sprechen von
gestalten und transformationen hierbei
spricht der wirtschaftsminister nicht
ein irgend unbeteiligter kommentator der
zuständig ist für den strukturwandel
nicht den menschen in den neuen
bundesländern aus der seele und wenn der
bundeswirtschaftsminister schon zu
beginn seiner amtszeit beim
strukturwandel keinen gestaltungswillen
erkennen ist dann erwarte ich zumindest
von ihnen als zuständiger staatsminister
den festen willen den großen worten den
sie heute
vorgetragen haben auch taten folgen zu
lassen ich sage es deutlich ich halte
das vorziehen des kohle ausstieg von
2038 auf 2.030 für falsch sie hatten
davon gesprochen dass wir in den neuen
bundesländern die tarifpartner stärken
wollen für gewerkschaftliches engagement
streiten weil das ist richtig in einem
gesamtgesellschaftlichen prozess mit der
ig bce und liebe sozialdemokratie das
kann doch auch an sie nicht vorbeigehen
haben wir uns für ein ausstiegsdatum von
2038 entschieden da haben sich junge
menschen engagiert die einen
ausbildungsvertrag unterschrieben haben
als maschinen- und anlagenführer dort
sind finanzierung die bis 2038
abgestimmt worden weil man sich
gewerkschaftlich und im
gesamtgesellschaftlichen prozess darauf
geeinigt haben und drei von vier
bundesländern sind in den neuen
bundesländern die mit dem strukturwandel
betroffen sind wir reden von einem
wegfall von 40.000 arbeitsplätzen und
der staatsminister für die neuen
bundesländer sagt zu diesem thema in der
ersten rede nichts das ist nicht
akzeptabel für uns als unionsfraktion
hier erwarten wir für von ihnen mehr
angriff auch innerhalb der
koalitionsparteien
wir brauchen unter anderem in diesem
bereich beschleunigte planungsverfahren
die ansiedlung von
forschungseinrichtungen und
bundesbehörden einige ist es angekündigt
das unterstützen wir und den zügigen
ausbau von straßen und bahntrassen dazu
gehört es natürlich auch dass sie für
die ostdeutschen interessen werben und
auch geld einwerben beim grüßen bader
grünen wasserstoffwirtschaft sind wir
dabei die unternehmensansiedlung im
bereich der mikroelektronik haben sie
nicht angesprochen dresden eines der
florierenden beispiele die gerade in der
aktuellen zulieferindustrie auch lösung
anbieten wurden von ihnen nicht genannt
da erwarten wir substanzielle
unterstützung und wir brauchen auch die
sicherung hochwertiger arbeitsplätze ja
wir haben 30 jahre lang strukturwandel
aber wenn wir 40.000 arbeitsplätze
innerhalb der acht jahre verloren gehen
lassen und jetzt in mecklenburg
vorpommern 2000 arbeitsplätze dort
disposition stehen dann kommt vom
zuständigen staatsminister nichts
das ist nicht akzeptabel herr
staatsminister hier müssen sie auch
ihren worten taten folgen lassen sich
einbringen und nicht nur runde tische
anbieten sondern auch gemeinsam
vorangehen und drittens und frau
staatsministerin sie haben das
angesprochen das gilt für uns natürlich
generell als gesellschaft wir müssen mit
ganzer kraft den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt stärken und dafür stehen
wir als union dafür stehen wir als
partei der wiedervereinigung jederzeit
an ihrer seite danke
zur rede des stellvertretenden unions
vorsitzenden
in der debatte um die politik der
bundesregierung
boris kanzleramt
der wunsch besteht offensichtlich
die bundestags-vizepräsidentin katrin
göring-eckardt hat hier noch mal etwas
gesagt dann jeder abgeordnete jeder
abgeordnete kann hier das rednerpult je
nach größe anpassen lassen und sepp
müller dass man sie gesehen haben ist
relativ groß er hat grunde spricht jetzt
für bündnis 90 die grünen erst kultur
und medienpolitischer sprecher
präsidentin meine damen und herren die
bewältigung der pandemie hat den
künstlerinnen und den menschen in der
kreativbranche in ihrer beruflichen
existenz bisher weltweit mehr abverlangt
als vielen anderen berufsgruppen als
kulturpolitik erinnern ist es ganz akut
unsere vordringliche aufgabe alles dafür
zu tun die kulturelle infrastruktur
unseres landes zu erhalten und die
existenzen im kulturbereich arbeiten der
menschen zu sichern denn kunst und
kultur tour sind gesellschaftsrelevanten
unser freies und vielfältiges land um
diese infrastruktur zu sichern wird die
neue regierung alle register ziehen
prekär war die arbeitssituation im
kulturbetrieb aber schon vorher künftig
werden wir eine bessere soziale
absicherung gewährleisten gerade von
freischaffenden von solo selbstständigen
und hybrid beschäftigten in kunst und
kultur etwa durch die einführung von
mindestlohn oralen im bundeskader
richtlinien oder eine langfristige
stärkung der ksk wir werden aber auch
über die in der ksk versicherten hinaus
denken müssen gerade die für den
kulturbetrieb so wichtige
veranstaltungsbranche verliert seit
beginn der pandemie mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter gerade in den ländlichen
räumen von technikerinnen stage 1 oder
sicherheitsdienste wenn wir
2022 einen kultursommer haben wollen
müssen wir hier noch mal scharf
nachdenken wie wir in diesem bereich
gegensteuern können
meine damen und herren aus der erfahrung
dass der holocaust möglich war das
universelle grund und menschenrechte
außer kraft gesetzt werden konnten
erwächst uns die aufgabe zu erinnern das
ist teil unseres demokratischen erbes
unser erinnern bedarf der rituale der
orte des gedenkens und auch der
bereitschaft sich unerforschten zu
stellen denn vieles ist auch 77 jahre
nach kriegsende nicht aufgearbeitet und
da wird die neue regierung rangehen etwa
an die verfolgungsgeschichte der sinti
und roma an die geschichte von
opfergruppen und die nachgeschichte der
euthanasie morde und zwangssterilisation
es braucht ein mahnmal für die
verfolgten und ermordeten zeugen jehovas
und es braucht deutlich mehr engagement
bei der provenienzforschung und der
restitution von ns raubgut ja und es
braucht so lange verdrängte
auseinandersetzung mit unserer
kolonialen vergangenheit mit der
kolonialen kontinuität bis heute die
dekolonisierung von stadträumen und vor
allem die rückgabe von kulturellem
eigentum und von human remains die noch
zu tausenden in deutschen
forschungseinrichtungen lagern
künftig wird es also verstärkt um
restitution und rück bereiten will mit
übergang eigenen gehen aber auch um eine
enge zusammenarbeit mit den herkunfts
besetzten meine damen und herren wir
brauchen eine erkennen dafür eine
moderne kultur politik und die
herausforderungen vor denen sie steht wo
es aus meiner sicht eine klare abkehr
von der bisherigen kulturpolitik der
union der letzten jahre braucht ist die
vorherrschende offensichtliche
gleichgültigkeit wenn es darum ging
klare kante zu zeigen gegen jede form
der umschreibung der relativierung
deutscher geschichte eine form der
gleichgültigkeit die dazu geführt hat
dass heute im zentrum von berlin über
dem humboldtforum eine kuppel inschrift
prangt die für das exakte gegenteil von
weltoffenheit steht die weltoffenheit
deutschland ist für uns als
ampelkoalition der grundpfeiler einer
gemeinsamen kultur politik
einherging diese jetzt abgelöste
kulturpolitik leider auch mit einem
zunehmend unkritischen preußen bild das
die vermeintliche glorie auch baulich in
szene setzt die aber militarismus
kolonial verbrechen oder die
kollaboration mit dem nationalen
sozialismus geflissentlich unter den
teppich kehren möchte das werden wir
nicht weiter zulassen
erinnerungskultur hört 95 wird sich
nicht auf die aufarbeitung der
sed-diktatur anhand der stasi unterlagen
muss weitergehen an orten mit dem campus
für demokratie auf dem gelände der
ehemaligen stasi-zentrale hier in berlin
aber auch an den orten der größten
deutschen demokratiebewegung der
friedlichen revolution in der ehemaligen
ddr
zur erinnerungskultur gehört für uns
aber ebenso die aufarbeitung der ns
mords wurde wie die geschichte von
flucht und vertreibung und die
entwicklung deutschlands vom
gastarbeiter land zum einwanderungsland
meine damen und herren der aufbruch in
eine klimaneutrale zukunft ist eine
notwendigkeit und zugleich eine chance
sie betrifft alle gesellschaftlichen
bereiche auch die kultur wir werden dem
kulturschaffen mit einer anlaufstelle
green culture des hierfür erstmals
beratung und finanzmittel an die hand
geben damit eröffnen wir chancen wie
auch durch eine geschlechtergerechte
förderpolitik durch die förderung von
diversität
unsere kulturstaatsministerin claudia
roth ich grüße sie ganz herzlich spricht
da von vorteil sein zu wollen partei für
die kunst und kultur das ist programm es
sagt klipp und klar die bundes
kulturpolitik günstig steht an der seite
derjenigen die kunst und kultur in
unserem land lebendig machen im dialog
mit ihnen im bewusstsein wie wertvoll
sie sind für unsere gesellschaft darum
wollen wir kunst und kultur als
staatsziel im grundgesetz verankern
darum werden wir die klassische
förderung von kultureinrichtungen voran
bringen aber auch die der freien szene
unabhängigkeit und freiheit der kunst
ist unsere agenda
unverzichtbar und entscheiden für eine
freiheitliche demokratie ist natürlich
ebenso eine freie presse sie wollen wir
stärken gegen alle versuche in eine
kritische und unabhängige
berichterstattung einzugreifen die
japanisch amerikanische musikerin
sängerin und politik yoko ono hat gesagt
kunst ist kein substantiv kunst ist ein
wert in diesem sinne werden wir ins
machen kommen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
der nächste redner ist martin renner für
die fraktion der afg
martin renner sitzt im ausschuss für
kultur und medien für tradition begrüße
ganz herzlich das präsidium aber auch
alle abgeordneten in den niederungen
dort unten im parlament aber ganz
besonders begrüße ich die kollegen hier
oben im olymp des hohen hauses
ja meint sehr ernstes problem
das heißt nicht corona sondern es heißt
spaltung
spaltung der gesellschaft
wir sprechen über integration und kultur
was ist das aber für eine kultur in der
wöchentlich hunderttausende demokratisch
spaziergänger bundesweit verunglimpft
beschimpft und kriminalisiert werden
bevor wir über integration sprechen
müssen wir zum wohle unserer
funktionierenden demokratie die risse in
unserer gesellschaft zu heilen beginnen
und zwar mit höchster priorität
dieser regierung aber auch schon die
vorhergehenden regierung bekommt nichts
in den griff das einzige was sie im
griff hat sind die medien ist die
politische wissenschaft sind die
agitatorisch wirkenden und
ideologisierten zivilgesellschaften
woher kommt diese eintönigkeit diese
uniformität die man eigentlich schon
gleichschaltung nennen könnte liegt es
etwa an den unzähligen maßlos
wohlgefüllten
fördertöpfen des staatshaushalts es ist
fakt die blanke zensur in den sozialen
netzwerken nimmt immer unerträgliche
ausmaße an
der sogenannte und angebliche kampf
gegen rechts wird immer unverhohlener zu
einem kampf gegen meinungspluralität zu
einem kampf gegen alternative medien zu
einem kampf gegen informationsfreiheit
und meinungsfreiheit
bedingungslose uniformität zwischen
medien und regierungs meinung und
erkauft der agitation und propaganda
darauf und kann es in einer
freiheitlichen demokratie nicht geben es
sei denn dass ein weg ins totalitäre
geplant ist die sozialen medien sie die
kommunikationsräume freier menschen mit
dem anspruch auf ihr christlich
fundiertes selbst eigentum die schon
seit jahrzehnten währende politik des
staates ist dabei die früchte der
aufklärung zu vernichten die damalige
befreiung des menschen aus den
absolutistischen bevormundungen und
unterjochung brachte die rede und die
pressefreiheit hervor und genau das war
und ist der kulturelle acker unserer
nation für freien öffentlichen diskurs
für these antithese und daraus folgende
synthese für freien wettbewerb der ideen
und damit für gesellschaftlichen
wohlstand wir brauchen hier dringend die
geistig moralische wende
affäre audi sowie ich deshalb allen
spaziergängen zu neuer dienst für unsere
freiheitliche rechtsstaatliche
demokratie ist von unschätzbarem wert
vielen dank ihr lieben spazierengehen de
mitbürger
renner warum
wundern wo er verstand es gibt hier eine
extra tribüne für abgeordnete die nicht
über ihren impfstatus auskunft geben
möchten da war auch das podium wo herr
renner stimmt thomas hacker spricht
jetzt für die fdp
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zurück
vom olymp eigentlich schärft den blick
in die weite der den geist aber
offensichtlich nicht immer wenn sich
eine
wende an die regierungskoalition am
anfang damit auf den weg macht kultur
als zentrales staatsziel im grundgesetz
zu verankern dann ist das mehr als nur
eine verfassungsrechtliche zäsur ist
aktives bekenntnis zur kultur ihren
institutionen zu den vielen menschen die
kultur ermöglichen gestalten vermitteln
es zeigt den unverzichtbaren wert der
kultur für unsere gesellschaft für
unsere demokratie ist es ein bekenntnis
dass wir für einen demokraten und schon
vor jahren für unser land gewünscht
hätten aber vielleicht haben gereicht
gerade die letzten beiden jahre unseren
blick geschärft uns deutlich gemacht was
uns fehlt wenn wir ohne konzerte club
besucher oder kinoabende leben müssen
viel zu lange hat es gedauert bis
erkannt wurde wie systemrelevant die
vielen kreativen die kulturschaffenden
doch sind oft liefen die hilfen ins
leere empfanden die menschen die
angekündigten unterstützungen als reines
lippenbekenntnis hier und wir andere
wege gehen und sehr geehrte frau dr
ein großes budget ist sinnvoll und gut
und ein signal man kann sich dafür
gegenseitig oder selbst auf die
schultern klopfen wichtig ist aber
welche projekte welche institutionen
gefördert werden und vor allem dass das
geld an auch dann bei den menschen
ankommt und hier ist leider die bilanz
etwas trüben mehr versteht wagen das ist
der gemeinsame anspruch von uns freien
demokraten von spd und grünen für die
nächsten vier jahre das gilt
selbstverständlich auch für die kultur
politik unseres landes die zeit der
reinen
symbolpolitik ist vorbei unsere kultur
ist doch so vielfältig und die version
sauerland selbst egal ob es sich um die
klassische musik in meiner heimat
bayreuth oder und graphic novels handelt
die ja mehr sind als bunte bilder
geschichten mit mäusen oder superhelden
und die nicht zuletzt über die property
ein weg in die museen oder als street
art in unser leben geschafft haben
kulturen gibt uns kulturen bringt uns am
abend uns jeden tag und überall in der
korona krise haben wir nfc neue digitale
bilder kulturen kennengelernt museen in
virtual reality besucht musikfestivals
im stream verfolgt diese neuen
erfahrungen diese neuen erfahrungen
tragen wir als koalition jetzt auch
rechnung wir wollen kultur mit allen
ermöglichen jede vielfalt und freiheit
sichern unabhängig von organisations-
und ausdrucksformen wir sind überzeugt
kulturelle und künstlerische impulse
können öffentliche debatten räume
schaffen unsere gesellschaft inspirieren
in diesem gemeinsamen verständnis setzen
wir uns in der ampel für eine
zukunftsweisende kultur und
medienpolitik 1
einer feststellung von claudia roth
herzliche grüße zu beginn dieser woche
braucht man eigentlich nichts mehr
hinzuzufügen indem wir die kultur
stärken stärken wir auch unsere
demokratie
wir leben ja täglich wie zerbrechlich
demokratie ist wir erleben täglich wie
die grundlagen unseres zusammenlebens
immer wieder in frage gestellt werden
und auch offen angegriffen werden
draußen aber leider auch immer wieder
hier in diesem hause dem wollen und
müssen wir uns entgegenstellen gemeinsam
und mit ganzer kraft
wir werden
wir werden die soziale lage in kunst und
kultur verbessern paritätische und
diverse struktur und fördern die
künstlersozialkasse finanziell stärken
und die grundlagen für kreative an der
webens lebensrealität ausrichten ein
ansprechpartner bei der bundesregierung
für die kultur und kreativwirtschaft
gibt sichtbarkeit und hilft dass
kreativität und innovation keine grenzen
mehr kennen und die gründung des
kompetenzzentrums digitale kultur ist
eine investition die wahl über
deutschland und europa hinaus wirkt
unser fokus auf die zukunft vorstellt
dabei nicht den blick auf die
vergangenheit unser kulturelles erbe und
unsere erinnerungs politische
verantwortung ist für uns anspruch und
verpflichtung zugleich
wir schützen und stärken unsere
erinnerungsorte und gedenkstätten in ost
und west wie war denn die
forschungsarbeit und die lokalen
initiativen und sichern den blick von
zeitzeuginnen und zeitzeugen für
künftige generationen
ich komme zum schluss frau präsidentin
der kultur kann man es sich wunderbar
bequem machen als gescheitert der
weltverbesserer oder als ausgebremste
büßten sogar eine anforderung für
claudia roth bequem machen wir uns nicht
es wird nicht bequem werden die wir
kollegin links sondern spannend vielen
dank
[Applaus]
also sprich die kollegen dr christiane
schenderlein zu uns für die fraktionen
der cdu/csu
und es ist ihre erste riege die wir uns
besonders freuen die
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich freue mich
sehr dass mir meine fraktion in der
neuen wahlperiode im bereich kultur
medien übertragen hat in meinem
heimatland sachsen gibt es viele
kulturelle schätze diese liegen nicht
nur in den großen zentren wie leipzig
oder dresden sondern vor allem außerhalb
im ländlichen raum so befindet sich in
meiner heimat nordsachsen mit der
hubertusburg in wermsdorf die größte
jagd residenz europas und um diese
kulturelle vielfalt im ländlichen raum
zu stärken haben wir in sachsen mit dem
kulturraumgesetz ein erfolgreiches
instrument für die kulturellen angebote
in stadt und land geschaffen aber
besonders große vorhaben wie zum
beispiel kulturhauptstadt chemnitz 20 25
könnten wir ohne den bund nicht stemmen
es war und bleibt von enormer bedeutung
dass kunst und kultur auch in
erheblichen maße vom bund gefördert
werden gerade jetzt die pandemie hat
alle gesellschaftlichen bereiche
getroffen die kultur und die in der
kultur tätigen menschen leiden besonders
hart darunter für die bundesregierung
muss es in den nächsten wochen und
monaten oberste priorität haben die
massiven folgen in der kultur und
kreativwirtschaft
abzumildern kultur ist systemrelevant
sie braucht perspektive eine art
masterplan dabei haben sie unsere volle
unterstützung
mit den förderprogrammen neustadt kultur
und dem sonderfonds für
kulturveranstaltungen in höhe von
insgesamt 45 milliarden euro haben wir
bereits eine wichtige grundlage gelegt
vor allem nichtstaatlichen einrichtungen
und projekten wird damit zumindest
finanz schnell geholfen wir begrüßen
auch dass frau staatsministerin rot das
thema erinnerungskultur als ein
herzensanliegen bezeichnet hat im
koalitionsvertrag hat das thema
kolonialismus ein eigenes kapitel die
aufarbeitung des sed unrechts und der
diktatur leider nicht und das mahnmal
für die opfer des kommunismus finden
auch leider keine erwähnung
unseren kulturellen reichtum müssen wir
erhalten das feld in die
mitverantwortung des bundes und der
kulturhaushalt des bundes hat sich in
unserer politischen verantwortung
verdoppelt und auf insgesamt stolze 2
milliarden euro erhöht und ich hoffe
doch eher hacker ihre auslastung
bedeuten nicht dass sie daran kürzen
wollen leider findet sich im
koalitionsvertrag
weder eine eigene aussage zum
kulturhaushalt noch ein klares
bekenntnis zur sicherung von bin des
bundes geförderten kultureinrichtungen
außerhalb der hauptstadt dabei wissen
wir doch alle wie wichtig diese zusage
ist das eben nicht an der kultur gespart
werden darf geben sie diese zusage für
sie heißt es im koalitionsvertrag
vielfalt und freiheit sichern für uns
heißt es freiheit und vielfalt sichern
freiheit bedeutet aber nicht nur die
freiheit der kultur und künste sondern
auch freiheit der medien und der
journalismus ähnlich wie die politik
werden aktuell etablierte medien und der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk zur
zielscheibe von demokratie und systemen
feindlichen kräften angriffe auf
politiker und journalisten werden leider
zunehmend präsenter immer mehr
bürgerinnen und bürger verlieren in
einer flut von falschinformationen den
überblick und bleiben im filter blasen
gefangen das resultat können wir aktuell
deutschland heute auf den straßen sehen
daher stehen wir als unions-parteien
auch in dieser wahlperiode an der seite
des öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks und
an der seite der freien privaten medien
wir fordern die bundesregierung in der
anstehenden wahlperiode zum konsequenten
kampf gegen fake news und gezielte
dessen aktionen auf
ich freue mich auf die weitere debatte
und auf die gemeinsame arbeit im
kulturausschuss vielen dank
[Applaus]
wir kommen zum vorletzten redner in
dieser debatte zur politik der
bundesregierung zum bundeskanzleramt das
ist helge lind wir sehen hier schon im
bild von den sozialdemokraten er ist
sprecher für kultur und medien seiner
fraktion
der kollege herr gelingt hat das wort
für die spd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
herr renner bei ihren anmerkungen aus
dem orkus haben sie etwas verwechselt
gleichschaltung betrifft nicht unsere
gesellschaft sondern die gesellschaft
das regime in dessen spuren sind schon
seit vielen jahren gehen soweit zur
historisch kulturellen bildung an dieser
stelle
wenn kunst es schafft die man
unwillkürlich zu tränen zu rühren dann
wird ihre macht und ihre stärke sichtbar
kurz vor weihnachten sah sich in irgend
einem hotelzimmer hier in berlin konnte
nicht schlafen und stieß zufällig auf
ein video das war das video der rede von
barack obama bei dem trauer gedenken bei
der trauerfeier für clemente bringt mehr
nach dem rassistischen massenmord von
charleston er spricht da bezugnehmend
auf
eine ihm befreundeten künstlerinnen
schriftstellerin von dem reservoir of
goodness dem reservoir von güte und er
kommt dann auf grace auf gnade zu
sprechen und spricht dann mehrfach von
amazing grace erstaunlicher gnade und
dann hält er einen moment inne
und dann beginnt er zu singen und der
ganze saal mit 1000 von menschen schweiz
erst und beginnt dann mit ihm zu singen
und alle stehen auf
man muss sich das klar machen und das
macht glaube ich deutlich was kultur und
kunst schaffen kann und kein anderes
medium kein anderer form ist da
vergleichbar denn er sagen dieses lied
mit menschen die opfer war von diesem
ort die angriffe waren aber die nicht
antworteten mit hass sondern mit
verzeihen die nicht aggressiv waren
sondern die
zusammenstanden und dieses lied amazing
grace das muss man wissen wurde
ursprünglich geschrieben von einem
kapitän eines sklaven schiffes der er
später zum abo die zionisten und zum
gegner der sklaverei wurde
diese zusammenhänge diese überwindung
von grenzen ist das was kunst und kultur
und was medien ausmachen wo mir reden
wenn wir daher
wie heute auch schon oft erwähnt mehr
fortschritt wagen wollen und sollen dann
ist das bei kunst und kultur aus meiner
sicht aus unserer sicht ganz stark im
sinne von brands mehr demokratie wagen
und das ganz präzise sowie dieser moment
den ich schilderte ein kultureller wie
zutiefst demokratische moment war und
das ist auch das was sich in dem
staatsziel kultur verbirgt und verbergen
muss
denn wenn wir uns angucken wie wir auch
im kulturellen bereich demokratie
fordernden entdecken sie aber auch wie
viele kulturelle einrichtungen heute
noch geprägt sind von gar nicht
demokratischen mechanismen wie schwarze
ballerinas
diskriminiert werden die patriarchale
und keineswegs gleichberechtigte
verhältnisse für und wie dann leicht
gesagt dass es die freiheit der kunst
und anders kann man nicht künstlich
produzieren was schlicht falsch ist das
heißt die demokratie ist auch der form
die einzug halten muss in kulturelle
einrichtungen dass es unsere kultur und
medienpolitische aufgabe zu aller erst
und
wenn wir dann tatsächlich ein solches
plenum der kultur von bund land und
kommunen und vor allem auch unter
beteiligung möglich starker
interessenverbände und der
zivilgesellschaft auf den weg bringen
dann macht das genau dann sinn wenn wir
demokratie da ernst meinen und pionierin
und pioniere von demokratie im
kulturellen bereich sind es macht keinen
sinn wenn es nur eine simulation von
partizipation wird es macht keinen sinn
wenn sie wieder zurückfallen in die
üblichen rituale der vorwürfe und der
schuldzuweisung zwischen den
verschiedenen ebenen bund länder
kommunen wer hat seine hausaufgaben
nicht gemacht oder doch all die rituale
die wir nicht brauchen das macht alles
keinen sinn und es macht auch nur dann
sinn wenn wir dieses plenum als auftrag
begreifen uns endlich klar zu machen
dass es nicht wirklich sinnvoll ist
künstlerin künstler dazu zu
konditionieren und zu trainieren
besonders nach projektanträgen zu
funktionieren unsere aufgabe als
koalition wird sein freies
künstlerisches schaffen zu unterstützen
und entsprechend auch fördersysteme zu
entwickeln
demokratie
und kultur bedeutet aber auch
erinnern zu begreifen und die lücken in
unserem erinnern zu sehen
was ist mit unserer
einwanderungsgesellschaft sie hat sich
was die mehrheitsgesellschaft betrifft
nicht ausgezeichnet durch eine fähigkeit
sondern eher durch eine unfähigkeit zu
erinnern zu empfinden und zu trauern
die afg und andere tun so als ob
rassismus eine erfindung von
identitätspolitik bevölkerungs wäre wenn
sie mal aber ich will dass den familien
nicht zumuten aber ihnen sollte man es
zumuten mit der familie gesprochen
hätten der familie unwahr
jankovic ins gesicht geschaut hätten in
die augen dann wissen wir was rassismus
in diesem land ein richtig anrichtet und
dann begreifen wir was für eine
unglaubliche leistung diese menschen auf
den weg gebracht haben nicht nur dass
sie ihren alltag bewältigen sondern dass
sie noch eine bildungs und
kultureinrichtung schaffen dass sie
aufklären dass sie nicht von hass
getrieben sind und nicht dieses land
verlassen sondern hier sind unsere
verdammte pflicht und schuldigkeit
gerade auch kultur medienpolitische ist
es diesen opfern diesen familien
unterstützung zukommen zu lassen bei den
einrichtungen bei die erinnerung das ist
keine leistung das ist nur das minimum
das ist schlicht die pflichterfüllung
unsererseits
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
können wenn wir von kultur und medien
heutzutage sprechen nicht über corona
schweigen nicht schwein einerseits über
die frage wie überhaupt die kulturelle
infrastruktur und die kulturelle
daseinsvorsorge am leben halten mit
finanzen mit unterstützung mit der
möglichkeit wieder veranstaltung zu
machen aber wir müssen noch etwas
anderes erzählen und das kommt mir viel
zu kurz ich glaube auf dem weg durch die
pandemie die ganzen fragen von
gesundheitsökonomischen hilfen haben wir
das ein stück weit vergessen diese
pandemie hat etwas mit uns gemacht und
dafür brauche es kunst und kultur das zu
bewältigen
menschen und individuen sind
traumatisiert seit zwei jahren hören wir
doch nichts anderes als instanzen
hospitalisierung sagen wir leben um uns
herum ich zuletzt gestern wie bekannte
gestorben sind wie andere in angst leben
andere wiederum isolation viele haben
ihre wirtschaftliche existenzen verloren
das hinterlässt spuren
wir leben in einer traumatisierten
gesellschaft und das spürt man auch
daran wie wir teilweise diskutieren über
die impfpflicht deshalb braucht es auch
kunst und kultur um dies verarbeiten zu
können und damit leben zu können und in
diesem zusammenhang die presse nicht für
die afrika und andere denken gut und
böse schuld absolut richtig und absolut
wahr nein es brauche nsn differenzierung
aber es braucht gerade eben nicht
diejenigen die sich in ihrer wagenburg
mentalität in ihrem selbstmitleid
verbarrikadieren die sich selbst immer
als opfer betrachtet die die besten
besserwisserei und rechthaberei pflegen
das ist es nämlich im kern was kulturell
liegt er denkt an bewegung ausmacht das
alles brauchen wir nicht sondern wir
brauchen eine kultur medien politik die
menschen ermutigt hier mächtig die nicht
die selbst trägt eame sierung feiert
sondern die tatsächlichen opfer
unterstützt und die begreifen dass
dieser kulturellen moment dieses
einzigartige etwas ist was jeder und
jede einzelne erlebnis deshalb gegen
[Musik]
ihre redezeit ist zu ende gewesen
deshalb grüße ich abschließend mit rio
reiser oder kulturstaatsminister die
heute nicht da sein kann mit seinem lied
war da ist am schluss hat wann wenn
nicht jetzt wo wenn nicht hier wie wenn
eine liebe während er nicht mehr
bezahlen müssen vielen dank ich habe
schon getöteten alle strophen empfehlen
dann
in raten hat jetzt das wort für die cdu
csu fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kollegen migration ist eine große
herausforderung für gegenwart und
zukunft und damit verbunden ist die
herausforderung des umgangs mit den
menschen die in unser land kommen und
für diese aufgabe wünsche ich der
bundesregierung aber vor allem auch ihm
persönlich frau staatsministerin alles
gute viel weitsicht und erfolg
integrationspolitik ist ein weites feld
es geht nicht nur um menschen die
geflohen sind sondern auch um fachkräfte
zuwanderung und eu arbeitsmarkt
migration all diese gruppen gilles in
den blick zu nehmen und für die
passgenaue programme aufzulegen so wie
es in der vergangenheit der fall war ich
denke zum beispiel an den beschleunigten
zugang zu integrationskursen und das
europaweit einzigartige modell der beruf
sprachkurse an beiden sollten wir in
zukunft festhalten und es
weiterentwickeln
wenn man
wenn man den vertretern der
ampelkoalition in der debatte zuhört
oder den koalitionsvertrag liest könnte
man meinen integration werde schon
gelingen wenn man jeder und jedem der
ins land kommen möchte zugang gewährt
ins land und zu leistungen egal woher
oder aus welchem grund jemand kommen
möchte oder bleiben will was sie sich
aber so schön ausmalen werde kollegen
wird in der realität nicht funktionieren
integration gelingt nur gemeinsam mit
den menschen in ihrem land sie findet
nicht in der theorie statt sondern vor
ort in den städten und gemeinden
sie kann nicht unbegrenzt gelingen denn
auch die kapazitäten unseres landes sind
endlich und ist sie es auch keine
einbahnstraße und erfordert das wollen
und mitwirken derjenigen die zu uns
kommen
integration
integration gelingt nur wenn es eine
breite akzeptanz für die regeln der
migration gibt und dazu ist eines klar
zu sagen ohne eine nachvollziehbare
ordnung und kontrolle bei der migration
wird diese akzeptanz der bevölkerung
rasch schwinden die unions griff die
unionsgeführte bundesregierung
hat in der vergangenen wahlperiode
gemeinsam mit der spd daran möchte ich
noch einmal erinnern gute mechanismen
für eine strukturierte migration und
integration erarbeitet im sommer 2009 10
haben wir an migrations paket
verabschiedet mit dem fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz können gut
ausgebildete und dringend benötigte
fachkräfte leichter zu uns ins land
kommen sie stärken unternehmen und
unsere wirtschaft und gleichzeitig
wurden maßnahmen zur bekämpfung
illegaler migration und eine konsequente
durchsetzung der ausreisepflicht
beschlossen das gehört eben auch in die
verantwortung der migrationspolitik
nun aber
werden von der bundesregierung
faktoren geschaffen die deutschland
verstärkt zu einem attraktiven ziel für
illegale migration machen können das ist
ein bedenkliches signal wenn wir eine
überlastung unserer sozialsysteme
verhindern und vor allem die
integrationsfähigkeit unserer
gesellschaft bewahren wollen auch darum
machen wir als union und weiterhin stark
für das prinzip des förderns und
forderns der nun von der ampel
vorgesehene weg markiert eine klare
abkehr von diesem bisherigen
integrations verständnis und hier vor
war nicht noch einmal ganz deutlich
werde kolleginnen und kollegen und zum
abschluss auch wenn ich kein gedicht
vortragen gewährt mir die präsidentin
noch ein paar sekunden möchte ich noch
eine weitere wichtige sache ansprechen
im koalitionsvertrag der bundesregierung
wird die integrationspolitik an vielen
stellen zu antirassismus und
antidiskriminierungspolitik umgeformt
und das halte ich in der form für
schwierig und zu einseitig frau
staatsministerin hat zu recht die
vorkommnisse und den anschlag in hanau
angesprochen und es sind alle einig dass
rassismus und extremismus entschieden
bekämpft werden müssen nicht jeder aber
der migrationspolitik und integration
vor ort kritisch betrachtet oder in
geordnete bahnen lenken will gehört aber
in die schublade der rassisten und nicht
jede fehlgeschlagene integration ist die
folge von diskriminierung lassen sie uns
bitte
frau kollegin sie dazu
genauer hinschauen in diesem sinne freue
ich mich auf die zusammenarbeit
[Applaus]
so weit die debatte zum
bundeskanzleramt